let's talk a little bit about the
endorsement game we do have a voicemail
number that number is two one nine two
david p many voicemails coming in about
the news that members of the squad
including alexandria casio courts has
congressman from new york will be or
already have endorsed Bernie Sanders in
the Democratic primary for president
here is one perspective that came in via
voicemail
hey David this is bill and Kelly
everyone is making a big deal about they
OC endorsing Bernie and maybe I'm
missing something but they're so closely
politically aligned she's basically his
protege all the Bernie Sanders are going
to be supporting a OC and vice versa
so I'm confused as to why you know the
YouTube for the progressive voices and
the corporate media and everything is
making such a big deal when I don't know
that ALCS endorsement is actually going
to bring in new blood to Bernie's
campaign new voters new interest or
whatever it seems to me that it's just
solidifying who's the base of Bernie
Sanders supporters are yeah listen we
talked about this yesterday on the bonus
show I'm open to having my mind changed
but that is basically my view Bernie has
a big deficit to make up mathematically
in the polls a lot of the constituency
of someone like AOC who is saying not
sure who I'm gonna vote for but once a
OC tells me who she endorses that's who
I'm going to go for a lot of those
people are already supporting Bernie
Sanders and so I don't think that this
is going to move the needle now the
eggman called in and he had an even more
cynical approach he believes that this
endorsement may hurt Bernie Sanders take
a listen to this hey Dave I think um the
squad backing Bernie right now is gonna
move the needle it could move the needle
away from him and that's it you're right
that people that like Bernie already
like her but people that are middle of
the ground people that like Bernie
and are kind of progressive are going to
see those super liberal economies
backing him and say no no that's too
much I have to go towards Warren or go
towards Biden so it's going to move the
needle away from iDEN and the squad
supporting him is right now going to be
the absolute turning point and it's
gonna be as close as he's ever come
right now this is gonna be it it's gonna
be Warren and Biden and I hate that I
really freaking hate that I love him he
started all of this and he's getting
shafted but it's gonna hurt him the
squad hello brother
yeah Shalom Eggman but I totally
disagree with the Eggman in this case
III don't believe that the aoc
endorsement is going to help Bernie take
the lead in the primary but I also don't
think the AOC or squad endorsements are
going to turn people away from Bernie oh
and I assume the Eggman is joking about
you know socialist communist whatever in
the squad because they're not at least
as far as as I've seen although they
certainly tend towards social democracy
and and more workers rights and anyway
that's not really the issue here I don't
think that this is an endorsement that
is going to do much one way or the other
but I am open to having my mind change
so let me know if I am misinterpreting
this we've got a great bonus show for
you today we will talk about how Elon
Musk's smoking pot on Joe Rogan's
program somehow ended up costing
taxpayers five million dollars how is
that possible we will talk about it we
will talk about how 34 of the best
selling quote fruit drinks targeted to
kids are not healthy not a surprise and
we will also talk about a Chicago
Teachers strike that is about to start
which will lead hundreds of thousands of
kids in limbo pros/cons and the impetus
for all of this all of these great
stories and more on today's bonus show
become a member or a patron to get
instant access